hey guys so today I'm making my dog dog
treats he is on a very specific diet
when he was little he had tons of
allergies basically felt like the first
year of his life in and out of vets
dermatologist we tried every possible
food combination and even now he has a
very sensitive stomach so my mom always
makes these dog treats but I ran out so
now I have to make the dog treats myself
so prepare yourself guys for a dog
cooking episode don't really consider
any of my youtube videos episodes we're
making dog treats today let me go get
the ingredient I'd also make sure you
get unsalted unsweetened peanut butter
too here want your dog to have any of
that okay we're going to learn greedy
instead of now I need to put it all in
and we're going to make it we're going
to make
[Music]
did you
he could
I'm making a mad well I think this looks
pretty good I had to add extra water
because I put too much peanut butter in
and some things were off so you know you
got to do what you got to do back in
there it says you can roll them into
little balls which I'm also going to do
but I'm also going to rule some out into
some nice flat little circle perfect
perfect little Matty treat kind of is
going to work to be honest with you
probably should have put it in the
fridge first
[Music]
Oh
I wasn't working great
[Music]
when it's preheating to 350 and we've
got our first tree done
look it says rolling these out is taking
a lot longer than I thought so I'm
probably just going to do the next batch
of little round balls because this is
quite a process
I don't even spend too much time making
food for myself Alexa set a timer for 22
minutes second time 22 minutes starting
this cookies on the oven I decided to do
two batches of the cookie cutter one but
I still have some left over so I guess
I'll just kind of make those on another
tray and hope for the best and wait for
these ones to finish up and then mattock
and driest treat I also like to put
these in the freezer because I don't use
them that often so I do like to keep
them either refrigerated or in the
freezer now you actually like some more
frozen so don't you have any idea what
I'm doing right now lovin life that's my
boy oh god it's so hot here they are it
looks good
ever let those cool and then we'll be if
Maddy likes them my angel before Maddy
tries them I have to try them
I mean it just tastes like cooked peanut
butter it's all bad
or it's really not good we'll see if
Maddie like this editrice come here this
book
yes that's my angel sick video and how
many did it good
[Music]
yes my baby boy that's my dog that's why
we call him DJ mini Matt take a tick oh
he's having both goodness up with the
recipe in the description of you guys
want to make this also I'm super excited
because he loves them and I know what is
in them or the hard thing is about
getting dog treats for dogs most doors
sell dog treats with stuff in them that
are not actually good for your dog of
course you should always treat
moderation let me know if you guys have
any recipes or things you can make sure
guys I would love to see them I'll see
you guys in my next video bye
[Music]